talking about envy convert which is a
tool chain for converting jupiter
notebooks into into other things other
file formats so i'm thomas cloupor I'm
based at the University of Southampton
and I'm kind of be the UK wing of the
Jupiter and ipython project and the
other the other person that we have at
the conference or people are min who's
based in Oslo Norway and Silvan who
isn't here today but he's based in New
York so before I before I get into and
be convert this is something that we try
to reiterate at every conference because
it's a message that we feel we're not
doing a very good job of getting across
so far this is what the what the
distinction between Jupiter and ipython
is so people still seem to use the terms
pretty much interchangeably so
everything it all was ipython up until
an including version 3 and then we
renamed large part of the project to
Jupiter and the rule is that everything
everything that can work with other
languages so all of the the notebook the
protocol that it talks to like send code
to the kernel and things and a lot of
the the higher-level projects like
Jupiter hub that min gave a tutorial on
that we had on Friday
that's all language agnostic that all
goes under the the Jupiter name and then
ipython is the Python specific
interactive tools so a big chunk of that
is the Python kernel for Jupiter so when
you're running Python code in a notebook
it is a Jupiter notebook with an i -
kernel and then I - is also it also has
its own like terminal interface so when
you just type ipython in a terminal and
you have the like in prompt in your
terminal that's ipython so hopefully
that's all clear
so back to and be convert which is what
I'm officially here to talk about that's
that's something I could give an entire
talk about but these are special like
convenience sin taxes within I Python so
if you do you can run any system command
by starting it with an exclamation mark
and you we have a set of these like
magic commands we call them which are
just like convenient functions that run
like shell style commands and they start
with a percent
yeah there's information on the internet
more about that because I could go into
these for the entire talk so and be
convert as a kind of a set of tools that
turn notebooks into other formats and
there are three three main pieces to the
N be convert tool chain so you start
with a notebook file or a notebook
object in memory that goes through pre
processors which are pretty much just
functions that act on the the notebook
and return a modified version of the
notebook exporters are what actually
turn turn that notebook object into some
other format whether that's HTML or
later or restructured text and then post
processors are additional functions that
act on the exported file after it's been
converted those don't get used much
anymore the originally when you created
a PDF it was a late exporter and then a
PDF post processor that ran late app now
we've made it so it's a PDF exporter
that includes running latex and so
actually there's there's one remaining
post processor and it's the one I'm
running right now which is the
a slide serving post-processor so there
are some bits of reveal.js that don't
work properly when you load it from a
file URL so we have a little HTTP server
to render slides like this
so you can use MB convert in a variety
of different ways probably the the most
common way is and be converted the
command line so you run Jupiter and be
convert and then there's a whole set of
options so - - two slides uses the
slides exporter and this is if you run
this inside this get repository but the
link will be at the end of the
presentation again then it creates the
presentation that I'm presenting from
but you can also you can also use it as
part of a pipeline so it can read a
notebook from standard in and produce
something - to stand it out so in this
in this example I've used it with the -
- execute flag so that's one of the one
of the people preprocessors it built in
2 MB convert allows it to execute a
notebook before rendering it so you can
ensure that it's up to date at the point
when you you rendered it and just an
aside because someone was mentioning to
me the other day that they they had
upgraded their notebook and then they'd
sent their supervisor a notebook and
their supervisors had said what I can't
update this and I'm looking I can't open
this and I'm not going to update my my
packages so if you find yourself in that
situation then this command will
downgrade your notebook - and be format
version 3 and that works for like
converting between any different
versions of the notebook format so 2
notebook is one of the exporters yes I
can see that the person who had that
problem just taking a picture of the
commodity
see if that can upgrade and downgrade
between all the versions of the notebook
format in practice if you if you want to
go back to a version older than version
3 at this point then then there's
probably some bigger problem that you
need to solve it's also so like most of
the stuff we do and we convert itself is
written in Python and you can use it as
a Python API so it's a bit more a bit
more involved than the command-line
interface but here you can see I'm
loading a restructured text exporter
then I'm using the in before map package
which is a separate package for reading
and writing notebook files to load this
notebook and I'm and then i'm using the
restructured text exporter and that it
just it gives me a string of
restructured text and then you know you
can carry on to do whatever you like
with that in the notebook or from your
Python code so I have a I have an
example notebook here for a side project
that i have called env parametrize so
you can see it's doing some kind of like
simple stock market calculation it's
going to draw a plot and the first cell
crucially here is has just plain
declarations so name equals and a value
and n be parametrized looks for that
first code cell and extracts those
assignments out and turns them into
parameters that you can see it lets you
replace those values and then rerun the
notebook with the new values so I have a
little web app demo so this has looked
at the notebook I have
I haven't hard-coded this this form it's
what's going on
I haven't hard-coded these parameters
into this web app it's looking at the
notebook and generating this form from
the notebook so we're here in Bloomberg
somebody somebody shout how to a stock
symbol what do you know the okay I
happen to know that one so that has just
executed the notebook and then it's used
and be convert in and be parametrized to
render it to HTML and serve it to me so
that's just one example of what you can
do when you have env convert as a as a
Python interface and just to give a a
shout-out to another example NB Spinks
is a tall that's it's not not part of
our not something that we work on it's
something that we actually use in some
of our Doc's but it's written by matias
gaia i believe and so this lets you just
have a a folder of I PI and B files in
your sort of Sphinx source tree and you
can put them into an index as you would
with a restructured text file and env
Sphinx will load those and render them
as part of a sinks template and so this
is an example that's on read the docs
and it hasn't come out very clearly
because of the way that the resolution
has changed but this is in fact part of
a part of a set of Sphinx documentation
so it has all of the like Sphinx sidebar
and table of contents and everything
integrated with notebooks so it makes it
that much easier to write dogs
and yeah this is a really neat tool and
enbe converts own Docs are by using this
and open that was because I didn't have
the internet running when I loaded the
web server and that this is how this is
something that I expect you've all seen
and be converted to a web service so
envy viewer is a site that you can go to
and you go to URL to a notebook file and
it serves you a rendered HTML version of
that that you know it's static it you
can't edit this or anything but it's a
super easy way to publish a notebook and
then you have it so this is one of peter
norvig fascinating sort of Python
explorations of the puzzle and this was
the the New Year's puzzle where you have
to fill in the operators in this in this
mathematical expression so this is yeah
NB viewer is a web service that runs and
we convert to HTML for you and we are
also looking at the possibility of
making like and be viewer to PDF because
getting the getting all of the latex
stuff that you need installs to convert
things to PDF is a bit of a challenge on
some systems so if we can provide that
as a web service and all the machinery
is it's there it just hasn't hasn't been
done as yet
okay so I'm getting to kind of actually
what I what the title of the talk said
this is which is customizing and be
convert so how can you make and we
convert do what you want
specifically rather than just using what
it already has
so most of most of RnB convert output is
built from templates so when I convert
something to reach restructured text
there is a built in restructured text
template and this uses the standard
ginger templating package which is
widely used for like Python web apps and
things and we have a template this kind
of template structure made up of blocks
and the cool thing about ginger
templates is they allow template
inheritance so you can define a template
that inherits from one of our templates
and override one of these blocks within
the block you have a super method so it
looks something like this
so this says we're inheriting from full
DPL which is our full HTML template and
then we're going to override the
markdown cell block and wrap wrap
whatever it would normally be in a div
with some style so this is kind of a a
trivial example that we called the the
make it pop template and that will just
give any markdown cell lay a glowing
background
so it's very easy with you know you're
reusing all of the templates that are
already in and be convert and all of all
of the structure here and you're just
sort of adding one little bit of
override to change what that's doing
possibly a a more practical example
here's another extension of the HTML
template so this has this is a bit more
complicated so it has some CSS I think
in this case because of the template
structure I had to copy and paste some
of the some of the stuff that was
already in the template and you can see
we're adding a little bit of JavaScript
and then we're doing some stuff down
here with a code cell
sorry that's a bit small and the result
of that is that if you convert a
notebook to HTML with this template then
the code cells are initially invisible
apart from the first one I think that's
a bug bugs happen and then you can you
can click this and you can hide and hide
and show any of the cells to the ability
to generate output without the without
the code visible as something that we're
asked for quite a lot and this this
template gives you the ability to do
that and you know if you if you don't
want these expand expand the code
buttons then it's even simpler because
you can just say like this is the code
cell block don't put anything in it
so another thing that ginger templates
have are filters so when in these double
brave spits you put sort of some Python
code more or less that results that
evaluates to the stuff you want to put
into the template at that point and
ginger has this syntax for kind of like
passing passing the text or the the
values through a pipeline of filters
there for it before it comes into the
template so we can be convert itself
defines several more of the several of
these filters ginger also has a few
built in and so these are basically just
Python functions that are going to take
something in return something
the return value gets passed on to the
next filter in the template and if you
make a custom exporter which I'll come
onto in a bit then you also have the you
also have the ability to UM to add
additional filters of your own and so
that gives you extra power to do things
in templates as the first one is from
the from the restructured text template
so that's taking some latex output
stripping off any dollar signs beginning
of the end which are sometimes used to
sort of Demark that something is latex
and then indenting it all by I think the
default is for spaces and the bottom one
is from the the HTML template and we
integrate and be convert integrates
pigments the Python syntax highlighting
library to do syntax highlighting of
your code so this is what this is what
makes sure that the code is syntax
highlighted when you convert to HTML
you can also do clever things in in the
template using using metadata so inside
any block related to a cell you have a
cell variable that you can use in the
ginger code and you can use cell
metadata to get at the mesh data that's
associated with a cell which is just
like a a json dictionary and you can do
things conditionally based on that mesh
data so the slide the slide template
actually is nope
sorry I seem to do that a lot okay good
I'll try not to do it again the slide
template is a good example of this so
when you create a slideshow using a
notebook you use these little drop-down
menus here to select like where a new
slide is going to start which bits are
going to sort of initially be invisible
and then appear on the slide as you
press button and the slide these these
get stored in these values are stored in
cell metadata and then the slides
exporter and the slide template use them
to cut it up into slides
so I also just had this example to
mention this is from the the latex
template and the sharp-eyed of you will
have noticed that it's using a different
kind of syntax to the other examples
they had before and so these all use
this curly bracket syntax which is the
default ginger template syntax and later
curly braces are already significant so
if they were relevant for the template
as well then you should spend forever
like escaping curly braces everywhere
and it would be a horrible mess so we
tweaked ginger has options to to specify
the template syntax so the latex
templates are all based around these
parenthesis rather than curly braces so
stepping up to exporters so exporters
are more powerful than templates so
there's strictly more things you can do
with an exporter and template exporter
is a 1:1 subclass of the main exporter
class so it is an exporter that controls
like setting up ginger loading the
template providing the filters and
filling it in there are several cases
where you might want to do this I'm
still working home so yeah the the
notebook exporter that I showed for like
converting between versions of notebooks
and things that doesn't use a template
that uses our env format library to
write a notebook file directly PDF
exporter actually subclasses without a
excellent thanks PDF exporter subclasses
that a tech exporter so it is using a
template to create the lay tech but then
it's also running late heck PDF latex
command on that latex file to generate
the PDF and you could have another you
could have another PDF exporter that
could use something like report lab to
go directly to
PDF or it could generate HTML and then
run like a headless browser or something
to print that to a PDF so if you want to
define your own exporter then this is
this is the basis of what you have to do
you subclass from NB convert dot
exporter and you define the output mime
type the default file extension that you
want the files it produces to have and
then this from notebook node method that
takes a takes a notebook object and and
resources is a dictionary that's yeah
don't worry too much about resources for
the moment but if you get into doing
this a lot then you'll probably find
users for it and it returns the output
and the modified resources if necessary
and that can be the resources can
include things like external files that
it refers to so if you have like images
then not all formats can have images
inline so it may have to have them as
separate separate components
so then how do you how do you actually
use your custom exporter and deliver it
to other people so you can you can use
an import path on the command line so
you can say env convert - - - and then
the name of your module dot the name of
your class and it will go you know in
this case from TPL live import my
exporter and it will use that as the
exporter class you can also use setup
tools entry points okay the one nice
thing about setup tools which it's it's
this mechanism that kind of allows you
to specify plug-ins for for python
systems so you can tell it when you when
you package your code up twitch dump api
you can give it some give it some
information saying like my code defines
a an NB convert exporter and you give it
a name and then similarly in this case
it's module name colon class name and
then that allows that allows people to
use this shorthand syntax so this name
matches up to this name here and yeah
that's that's me just about half now
thank you any questions
so normally and B converts like I'm
giving these examples mostly for using
it at the command line and so you
install and B convert so if you've got
the notebook installed you have env
convert as part of that actually you can
use it from the notebook in the file
menu there's a download ass option
that's using NB convert and yeah other
than that it's just sort of the
extensions I've I was talking about are
like writing go writing a Python module
so dot py file and putting that
somewhere that it can be imported
that's the only time the only thing I
had when I was inserting some images
into files I was using the markdown
notation sometimes I use the HTML
so for converting to PDF I think so for
turning the returning markdown cells
into PDF we use a tool called pan dock
which is actually like an external
program it's written in Haskell of all
the things and I think that will
definitely be able to handle at the
markdown image notation
I don't yeah it may it may not be able
to do that yeah yeah that's one one
thing that you could do I guess is you
could display the images ask the result
of a Python cell and then it can end it
it you can when you display an image
object from ipython you can set like
width and height parameters and I'm
pretty sure that that should be exported
to PDF okay but then you will have an
extra an extra code cell you could come
up with a template trick with some cell
metadata or something to hide that yes
yeah
sure so that was this one yes and so and
be parametrized is a a package that you
can pip install and I I fully agree that
it has a horrible name suggestions for
better names are welcome and it it's the
package itself is actually pretty simple
it goes through and looks for the first
code cell and then it has in principle
it has like backends for different
languages in practice the only one
that's implemented yet is Python but
it's depending on the notebook metadata
it will pick an appropriate back-end and
ask the backend to pass that cell and it
turns it into a series of structured
objects that say you know name value
type and that's so it has yeah
two steps retrieve parameters from
notebook
fill in modified parameters to notebook
and then this demo wraps it into a
little web app and so it retrieves the
parameters generates this this HTML form
and then you you pick the values and
when you press go it it turns turns
those into the it returns those values
to the structured objects that that NB
parameter is created for you and asks
env parametrize to put them back into
the notebook and then you have a
notebook object it passes that try and
be convert and says turn this into HTML
for me and it executes sit first
yes so the when UNB convert to HTML we
have two templates that you can use
basic is like just the just the HTML
structure for a rendered notebook
without any of the kind of page stuff
like CSS and the you know head section
and full is the template that actually
renders a full HTML page
yes
yes please sir please come and find me
later so that we can work out what's
going on with that and how to get it
fixed
oh yes so the reveal where it loads
reveal is part of the template but part
of the slides template and yeah you can
you can totally take that template and
and override bits of it I don't know
that there's a specific block that you
can override like just the reveal
section so you might have to copy and
paste some stuff yeah obviously running
this but if I download the notebook is
there anything else that I need after
book installed and and so you need and
be parametrized so that's a separate
project on github yeah so you can you
can pip install the MV parametrize tool
and then this is in the examples
directory and it's called web app and
see you run web app dot pi and then you
give it the name of a notebook so this
stock display is the example that I was
using there alright I think that's all
the questions so let's go and get good
seats for lightning talks